so like when I told my mum that I was
gonna do began uary she kind of gave me
a funny look hi my name is Debbie Choi
and I am a personal trainer I started
for January to see if I could test
myself and give up milk cheese dairy
honey and all these other things I've
always wanted to be open-minded and I
don't want to judge vegans and that you
can't really judge someone until you've
done it yourself hi I'm Ben Coomer
nutritionist and I'm taking part in the
January to understand all about the
vegan diet and what it takes to
transition from an omnivorous diet to a
vegan diet but here we go
began uary week 1 good morning and I
just thought I would show you my
breakfast which is all vegan here's so
much about vegetarian diets vegan diets
and there are so many cookbooks out
there and programs and celebrities going
meat lessons and yet if you look around
the globe the consumption of meat is
still growing carving on meat and sugar
consumption could help us live longer
and save the planet according to a group
of 37 experts from 16 countries the
suggested diet allows for an average of
just 14 grams of red meat per day that's
a apparently a beef burger around 90%
smaller than a regular supermarket
portion it's just impractical and I have
to really ask why do we want to keep 11
million people alive longer than they
naturally should live where is the world
going with reproduction dairy production
where's the population growing - can we
sustain that in the way that we should
it takes so much energy to make the meat
that is better if we ate things from
more plant-based sources that don't use
so much energy to make the meat and we
can't carry on as we are eating
as much meat for the environment meat
does play a part in festivities but it
is absolutely possible to go on to
towards more plant-based eating and
still get a full range of nutrients as
long as it's well-designed and you think
about where those nutrients that you're
going to be lacking when you cut down on
meat and dairy where those nutrients are
going to come from woke up at one
o'clock in the morning quite hungry and
just kind of right thinking about food I
don't often think about food in that way
but I was like God like I am missing
some stuff but I can't you know judge
too quickly I've changed my diet a fair
bit I no longer have any animal protein
in it no dairy and that is a fair amount
of change my body is gonna have to get
used to that you know moving into day
four and five what I need to do now is
get more creative in the kitchen if
there's one thing that you have to make
sure you do on a vegan diet it's get
creative like the convenience aspect is
really tough on a vegan diet so I need
to get better with protein sources
because I am really struggling now with
satiation I've woken up this morning
I've had quite a lot of protein I've
cooked a big Thai curry and I'm just
still not satisfied it doesn't help them
a bit tired
and they're really good they are
supporting the Gagne and have some
really good options to choose now they
also have vegan cake which is really
helpful to broccoli essential food yes
veggies mushrooms I don't think the
health aspect of being vegan is too hard
I think it's society the reason why we
are drawn to me and nearly every meal
contains meat in it I often compare me
to sugar because our ancestors evolved
to love needs in a similar way they
evolved to love everything that's sweet
yes today both those things are no
longer as good for us as they were if
our ancestors
I need to spend more time in the kitchen
it's as simple as that
I need to get more creative with protein
sources I'm farting an awful lot I'm
doing about five poos a day it's
ridiculous I hope that settles down I
know that any dietary change leads to a
change in how your bowels operate
whether it's less or whether it's more
definitely I'm definitely farting a lot
so while those cows might be fine a lot
so am i we we believe me this is very
important for us socially and culturally
because meat was always something that
was connected to power and wealth and
masculinity and we still see it like
this these days even though you know you
don't have to be a brave hunter and
practically masculine to get meat these
days in the Western supermarkets
Trump steaks are the world's greatest
steaks and I mean that in every sense of
the word Trump steaks are by far the
best tasting most flavorful beef you've
ever had quality that belong in a very
very select category of restaurant and
our Certified Angus beef prime there's
nothing better than that
luckily I've not experienced too many
problems with eating out and being
around friends I think sometimes eating
me is maybe quite almost a masculine
thing and you know you might go out of a
group of guys and they might be
estranged when you order a bean burger
rather than a meat burger so there's
probably an issue there with a few kind
of guys but I'm I'm quite forthright in
what I want to do I'll stand up for my
opinions and I'll just say I'm doing
this because of this and I think my
friends respect that I am asking my
friend's wedding today and this is what
am weary and so when I got the invite I
put myself down as vegetarians we'll
just have to see what it's like doing
the January being a wedding gasps and so
I was a vegetarian from a wedding
breakfast and then in the evening I
tried to make more vegan choices and I
didn't have the confidence to kind of
say anything and say that I'm doing
forgetting you arey
so one of the key things that I've
noticed over the last sort week to 10
days is my gym performance it kind of
feels like he's gone down I don't feel
as strong I don't feel like this as much
in the tank if I would traditionally
train for like an hour and a quarter for
example which is quite common for me
three times a week then I'm kind of
gassing out around the 45 50 minute
marker just there's just not as much in
the tank that's all I can describe it as
it's not as cut it's not a carbohydrate
issue because I'm eating plenty of
carbohydrates as you could imagine on a
plant-based diet so I'm not really sure
it can be difficult to get enough
calories on a purely plant-based diet
and I find that people who are quite
athletic struggles get enough calories
to meet their knee I've been really ill
the past couple of days just like cold
symptoms and sore throat so I think I'm
just a little bit rundown I'm not sure
if it's because of the vegan diet I
don't want to say it is but I might just
have a bug because it's January it's
just got quite bad past couple of days
where I haven't been able to exercise is
because I've been so so like aching and
sore and like tar I'm all I'm always
tired which is really weird so the sorts
of nutrients that you find it abundantly
in meat and dairy based diets that you
may not find in a plant-based diet
include calcium iodine iron and vitamin
b12 and even omega-3 fats which you find
in oily fish so if you're not getting
enough iron you could feel tired
and out of breath morning said I am
looking after you CrossFit today I
really don't feel still not a hundred
percent Wow
yeah but I haven't exercised in about
two or three days because it's so achy
I just hope that I feel better soon
because I really don't like feeling like
this and I I don't want to say it's
because of the vegan diet but I don't
really know maybe I'm just not getting
enough nutrition or maybe I'm just not
eating healthy enough one of the things
that is definitely improved is my hunger
I don't really feel anymore like I'm
missing something that oh my god like
where's where's the lump of me on my
plate I don't have that anymore
and because I've varied my protein
sources I've tried lots of different
things now I'm enjoying the different
protein sources that I'm having trying
to do different things with tofu it's
still okay the secret to tofu is
definitely marinating it and spending
some time so one of the aims or one of
the things that I wanted to try and see
your experience from you know going
vegan is whether there's any change in
my health and at this point in time I've
only seen negatives I haven't had any
positive changes in like my energy or
God like my libido just anything like I
don't buy into any kind of oh this is
healthier from what I was currently
doing for me when a lot of people say I
went vegan or I went something and I
felt really healthy I felt really good
my question is always what were you
doing before
how were you eating and for most people
they weren't eaten that great and so one
thing that I've learnt is that like for
January isn't really a diet that you
should be trying to do if you're looking
for like a bit of a health kick it's
really not a diet for that
but it is a good diet to do if you are
looking at trying to broaden your
thoughts on animal welfare and the
environment after taking part in the
January I've decided that I probably
won't carry on being vegan and probably
go back to being more of a a flexitarian
plant-based diet just because I've
always eaten for health and I'd rather
eat occasionally like a organic
free-range piece of me instead of some
sort of process soya bean patty meat
alternative thing or like have eggs like
organic free-range eggs occasionally
instead of like again some sort of egg
vegan egg substitute tofu scramble thing
but apart from that I've really actually
enjoys doing for January and yeah I've
learnt a lot from it it could be
counterproductive to go to extremes with
lots of meat based foods or a completely
vegan diet moving towards more
plant-based eating still does your bit
for the planet and it's easier to get
your full range of nutrients doing began
uary has definitely made me think a lot
broader about my food all the different
options that are available getting
different nutrients onboard it's also
made me reengage myself with the bigger
picture of the world
what's happening with climate change is
our meat industry and dairy industry
impacting that is the way that we're
eating right now
sustainable ten 15 20 years time because
I want to keep being healthy and happy
and support the food industry for a long
period of time so it's reengaged me with
that because I think we lose sight of
that in our day to day of just eating
buying we go into a supermarket and it
could be quite a cold process because
just all the foods there and we can eat
whatever we won't want we don't even
have to engage with what's happening on
the bigger picture but now I really do
think we do have to engage with the
bigger picture of our food industry
you